[Musique]
et deux
l'ondh à votre avis pourquoi apprend
temps à lire vous lever le doigt
vous le verrez ce sera oui patrice pour
les stations de métro
oui alors sylvain aucune idée la lecture
c'est quelque chose d'utilitaires je
dirais fonctionnel qui sert à se
débrouiller dans l'existence dans la
société
alors ça c'est leur première idée et
elle est vraiment très présent chez eux
ensuite les adultes savent lire les
enfants ne savent pas lire au fond on
pourrait dire sans exagérer beaucoup que
pénétrer la lecture c'est aussi pour eux
d'une certaine façon pénétrer les mulets
les choses qui sont comme la sexualité
des choses spécifiques aux adultes c'est
une façon de grandir
alors une fois qu'on a acquis cette
autonomie et ce pouvoir qu'est ce qui se
passe mais il se passe que les lectures
perd un peu de son intérêt
on lit beaucoup à l'école on lit au
début parce que c'est intéressant se
démontera soi même qu'on a un pouvoir
et puis après la lecture est une
activité scolaire vous avez des enfants
qui vont continuer à utiliser ce pouvoir
et c'est devenu quelque chose de tout à
fait normal qu'ils diront beaucoup
puis d'autres enfants qui sauront lire
1.6 c'est à dire que quand on dit que
les français ne lis ça on veut dire tout
simplement qu'ils ne lisent pas de
littérature je crois que c'est la bonne
réponse
en fait nous lisons énormément nous
passons notre vie à lire sans en être
conscient est ce qu il ya de bonnes et
de mauvaises lectures non il n'y a pas
de bonne ou mauvaise lecture toute
lecture d'abord toute lecture activité
est bonne c'est bien lire c'est bien de
devenir quelque chose qu'on a envie de
lire deuxièmement on appelle bonne
mauvaise lecture des choses qui sont
considérés par d'autres comme pas bonne
sur le plan de la morale ou de la
culture
or pour finir chacun lit ce qu'il a
envie de lire lee ce qui lui fait
plaisir ce qui lui fait envie ce qui lui
est utile et on ne peut juger on ne peut
pas juger si c'est bon
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que chacun
fait sa lecture en fête
le lecteur est libre il fait de la
lecture ce qu'il veut ce qui veut dire
que comme on ne sait pas ce qu'il va
sortir de cette lecture elle n'est ni
bonne ni mauvaise
elle est bonne ou mauvaise pour lui
[Musique]